تجدد الغارات حسبما يبدو واستهداف لعدد من
المنازل ماذا لديك في التفاصيل
في هذه الاصوات حقيقه ناجمه عن قذائف
اطلقتها القبه الحديديه قباله المناطق
الشرقيه لمدينه غزه على وجه الخصوص نستطيع
رؤيتها بالعين المجرده لكن حقيقه نحن لم
نشاهد اطلاق صواريخ باتجاه الاهداف
الاسرائيليه من هذه المنطقه على الاقل
التي نستطيع ان نشرف عليها ونراها بالعين
المجرده ونرى تفاصيلها وبالتالي هذه
القذائف ثلاثه قذائف صاروخيه اطلقتها
القبه الحديديه في اجواء
محافظه مدينه غزه وبالتحديد في المناطق
الشرقيه لكن هذا ليس الحدث الوحيد هذا
ياتي على راس سلسله الغارات العنيفه التي
عادت لتستهدف منازل
المواطنين الفلسطينيين في مختلف المحافظات
منطقه الشمال كانت مسرحا لاستهداف المنازل
راينا قبل قليل غار منزل في منطقه
الفاخوره بجباليا شمال قطاع غزه والمنزل
دمر بالكامل وبالتاكيد بعد ان استهدف بشكل
مسبق من قبل الطائرات الاستطلاعيه او
المسيره الاسرائيليه عادت الطائرات
الاسرائيليه الى استهدافه فضلا عن استهداف
لعدد من المناطق في الحزام الشمالي لقطاع
غزه وهو الامر الذي ينطبق ايضا على
المناطق الجنوبيه وبالتالي عادت الاجواء
لتوتر شيئا فشيئا لابد من التنويه بانك
اشرت الى استهداف احد المنازل المنازل
شمالي قطاعي غزه ونحن كنا نشاهد الصور
لاستهداف هذا المنزل وحسب ما كان واضحا
بانه استهدف بغاره ادت الى تدميره بشكل
كامل وائل وائل من الواضح بان هنالك عوده
الى استهداف المنازل وانت ذكرت ذلك
سابقا ما عدد المنازل التي استهدفت اليوم
الى حد الان وكيف تبدو الرساله بالمقارنه
مع الايام الماضيه كيف يبدو التصعيد او
القصف او الغارات بالمقارنه مع الايام
الماضيه
بالتاكيد اليوم يعني هنا يعتبر هناك عدد
من المنازل يعني على الاقل اربعه منازل
استهدفت منذ فجر اليوم من قبل الطائرات
الحربيه الاسرائيليه ودمرت بالكامل في
الساعهتين الاخيرتين تم استهداف ثلاثه
منازل في مناطق متفرقه من قطاع غزه لاسيما
في منطقه جباليا ورفح جنوبي قطاع غزه
وكانت قوات الاحتلال او الطائرات الحربيه
الاسرائيليه استهدفت منزلا لعائله بشير في
منطقه دير البلح وسط قطاع غزه ولكن بعض
استهداف بعد استهداف هذا المنزل
لعائله بشير في منطقه دير البلح ساده
الهدوء الحذر الذي كنا قد تحدثنا عنه
لساعات طويله ما لبثت الاوضاع انهارت
ولم يعد هناك هدوءا الان القبه الحديديه
تطلق المزيد من صواريخ اعتراضات اعتراضها
في ذات المنطقه فدا حقيقه لكن
يتكرر نفس السيناريو لم نشاهد اطلاق
صواريخ لا من هذه المنطقه ولا حتى من
مناطق بعيده نسبيا حتى تطلق القبه
الحديديه صواريخ الاعتراضها
ونحن صراحه لا ندري هل هو خلل من من القبه
الحديديه او ان هناك صواريخ تاتي من مناطق
بعيده من جنوب قطاع غزه نحن لا نستطيع ان
نرصدها او نتحدث عنها وبالتالي القبه الان
عادت لتطلق صاروخين على الاقل كما قلنا
وكانت قد اطلقت في دقائق معدوده ثلاثه
صواريخ اخرى اذا الان الاجواء تعود الى
التوتر اكثر فاكثر شيئا فشيئا مع استمرار
هذه الغارات ومع استمرار بعض الرشقات
الصارو خيه التي شاهدناها انطلقت من مناطق
مختلفه من قطاع غزه
والجانب الاسرائيلي وعلى لساننا نتنياهو
يقول انهم مستمرون ماذا تقول الفصائل
الفلسطينيه بعد اربعه ايام من الغارات
الاسرائيليه المتواصله على القطاع والرد
الفلسطينيه عليها باطلاق صواريخ من قطاع
غزه
الفصائل الفلسطينيه تقول ايضا هم سيستمرون
طالما استمر الاحتلال الاسرائيلي في
غاراته وفي عدوانه على قطاع غزه وفي
استئنافه او تفعيله لسياسه الاغتيالات بحق
النشطاء الفلسطينيين
وبالتالي هذا عكسته
النيران على الارض عكسته التحكم من قبل
المقاومه الفلسطينيه في نسق هذه النيران
ومدى هذه النيران وعدد الرشقات التي تطلق
عدد الصواريخ نوعيه الصواريخ مدى هذه
الصواريخ وتزامن هذه الصواريخ ولكن كما
قلنا ايضا عكسته التصريحات التي صدرت عن
غرفه العمليات المشتركه والتي قالت بانها
تتحكم بشكل حازم في هذا النسق
وبالتالي قالت ايضا بان الاطلاق على
باتجاه مدينه القدس
على رسائل لابد لكل الاطراف بما في ذلك
اسرائيل فهم مراميها ومدلولاتها وانما
يجري في القدس يجري امام اعين الفصائل
الفلسطينيه وغرفه العمليات المشتركه وفي
هذا اشاره الى مسيره الاعلام التي اعلن
نتنياهو وحكومته بانها سوف تاتي كما هو
مخطط لها وسوف تمر من الحي الاسلامي كما
كما يبدو في استفزاز اضافي للفصائل
الفلسطينيه ولذلك قالت الفصائل وغرفه
العمليات المشتركه بان قصف اليوم في محيط
مدينه القدس المحتله له علاقه بهذه
التصريحات الاسرائيليه فيما يتعلق بمسيره
الاعلام وبالتالي هذا يعني بان
الموجه ربما تستمر لهذا التاريخ المزمع هو
يوم الجمعه القادم
وكما يبدو فان الفصائل الفلس تقرا المشهد
الاسرائيلي وتدرك تماما ان الوقت لا يعمل
لصالح نتنياهو وحكومته بشكل كبير وربما
تريد استغلال هذه النقطه من الضعف كما
تصنفها الفصائل الفلسطينيه ولذلك ربما
كانت هذه الرشقه باتجاه مدينه القدس والتي
تلتها هذه التصريحات لنقل الرسائل الى
الجانب الاسرائيلي وكل الاطراف ولذلك
وربما نشهد شيئا ما خلال الساعات القادمه
ماذا ستحمل الساعات القادمه هذا ربما ما
يمكن ان نرصده في تطورات الاحداث لكن كان
لافتا فدى ايضا ان هناك عددا من التصريحات
صدرت حتى عن الناطق باسم حركه حماس الذي
قال بان الفصائل الفلسطينيه تدير الاوضاع
في غرفه العمليات المشتركه بشكل مشترك
وتدافع عن
هناك تصريحات مماثله كانت بان اداره
المعركه باقتدار وحنكه وبتكتيكات عسكريه
جديده انما افشلت السياسه والمخطط
الاسرائيلي
بالاستفراد بحركه الجهاد الاسلامي
ونشطائها العسكريين في قطاع غزه على الرغم
من سياسه الاستهداف والاغتيالات التي
تمكنت من اغتيال خمسه من قاده سرايا القدس
لكن كان واضحا بان حكومه نتنياهو ارادت من
وراء هذا الاغتيال الكبير انما ارادت
عمليه خاطفه
وهجوم خاطف يحقق بعض الانجازات يسوق لصور
انتصارات بشكل كبير تتبعه موجه تصعيد
محدوده جدا لا تستمر لايام ربما ليوم
ليومين ومن ثم تتدخل الاطراف والوسطاء
وتضغط على الجميع من ثم يتوصلون الى وقف
لاطلاق النار الاداره الجديده للمعركه في
الميدان والتي نشاهدها للمره الاولى كما
قلنا فدا ربما ربما اوهمت بعض المراقبين
وبعض الاطراف بان بالفعل تم توجيه ضرباتله
وقاسمه
لسرايا القدس وغرفه العمليات المشتركه
للفصائل الفلسطينيه وبالتالي ربما اطمعت
اسرائيل بان تستمر في عمليه الضغط عندما
صمتت الفصائل الفلسطينيه وغرفه العمليات
المشتركه لاكثر من اربعين ساعه في باكوره
وبدايه هذا العدوان على قطاع غزه ربما فسر
البعض بان هذا ضعفا هذا ارتباكا هذا ربما
قسم ظهر الجناح المسلح لحركه الجهاد
الاسلامي وكسر التسلسل الهرمي لقياده هذا
الفصيل المسلح كما جاء في تصريحات نتنياهو
وغيرها من التصري الامنيه والعسكريه لكن
بعد ان قررت المقاومه الفلسطينيه البدايه
في الرد ووصول الرد الى ضواحي تل ابيب
بالتاكيد اعاده التوازن ان صح التعبير او
الردع مقابل الرضع الى حد كبير لكن يوم
امس عندما راينا
رشقات صاروخيه جديده على دفعتين باتجاه
مناطق وصلت ايضا الى في ضواحي تل ابيب
ومناطق اخرى بالتاكيد اعاده التوازن لكن
كان هذا
اذا رسائل متعدده ترسلها الفصائل
الفلسطينيه الى الجانب الاسرائيلي